hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game it's from round three of
the ultibox norway championship and even
though the event has already finished
and we know who won
and with how many points uh we still
said that we are going to
cover some of the nicer games and some
of the games that you guys suggested so
this is a game from round three
uh alireza firucha vs fabiano caruana
and this is uh
this is an armageddon game so to say
because their classical game was drawn
and then they immediately play an
armageddon game so this is one event
that is special like that uh it's
impossible for a round to end in a draw
so you can draw the classical game but
uh then you play an armageddon and you
will either uh
well you will gain some points
but not half which you would in in a
classical setting
so it's uh very interesting and it's uh
it features a line that
has never been seen before and it's
quite quite an exciting line i'm sure
you guys are going to enjoy it uh let's
dive straight into it so furuja with the
white pieces opens with
knight to f3 we have the retti uh
opening uh
d5 we have d4 and now knight to f6 so
through a bit of a different move order
we transpose into the coal system with
e3 and
c5 alireza grabs the c5 pawn
and now e6 preparing to capture it but
now
before uh defending that
that extra pawn which is something uh
where thought uh taught as children to
never do as you're gonna run into a lot
of trouble
uh but uh you know it's 2020. now we
have help
from uh really strong computers we have
help from uh ai
from uh from lila from alpha zero and
you know
new new things are being learned every
day so here a5
this is the way i learned it uh where
you know through books
you just attack these uh uh these pawns
that are that are defending the
uh the extra pawn that white is trying
to keep so here's c3
uh and a characters on b4 we have c
capture sun b4
and now b6 again trying to get white to
capture to go bishop to b for
check uh and so on so here alireza goes
bishop to b5 check and this is nothing
new this has all been played before
bishop to d7 blocking and now bishop
captures on d7 however here's the
difference
uh known moves here are knight b
captures on d7 and the knight
f captures on d7 however the move fobby
plays
queen captures on the e7 is a new move
and now it's uh already as of move nine
that we have a completely new game
and here uh alireza's plan is to not
worry about this but actually just play
a4 sacrifice upon
to get two connected pass points on the
queen side and this is what's uh
what's really awesome here five he grabs
it b cap b captures on c5 and now b5 and
this is what i meant
uh it's only move 11 and already alireza
has two connected pass pawns
on the queen side it's not all that uh
bad for fabi either
because he's up upon and he already has
a past c pawn so it's gonna be
it's going to be a crazy game fabi
continues developing he wants the castle
he goes bishop to d6
and bishop to b2 uh an excellent uh
square for the bishop on this long
diagonal and fabi says i'm not worried
about capturing on f6 i'm just going to
castle and
if you capture you're just giving up a
beautiful
dark square bishop you're going to mess
up my pawn structure a little bit but
i'm not
i'm not told that where you you don't
have any sort of an attacking setup
going on here
so here just knight b32 fabi continues
develop
sorry alireza continues developing and
uh we have c4
uh opening up the bishop while uh
pushing his past pawn with queen to c2
and now queen to c7 uh we have castles
by ferruja
and now knight b to d7 the knight has a
lot of options here you can come to e5
uh to c5 to b6 all depending on what
white plays
uh and here uh you don't want to well
constantly have to worry about what
happens if this pawn lands in c3 just
bishop the c3
and this will give you additional
support for for pushing your pawn to a5
as now the bishop and the rook are
defending it
so here knight to c5 from here the
knight can come to e4 then i can come to
d3
uh and now alireza doesn't wait waste
time with rook f2b1 to add support
uh to his pass pawns but rather just a5
right away so uh very interesting
uh but those pawns are are marching up
the board
uh here after a5 we have knight f to e4
uh offering some trades here and uh here
knight to d3
was also an idea fabi prefers knight f
to e4 and now just
b6 all there is a continuous pushing we
have queen to b7 keeping an eye on the
a6 square
and now bishop to d4 uh just uh keeping
keeping the tension fabi trades a pair
of knights knight captures on the e2 we
have knight captures on d2 and now
knight to d3 the other knight finally
lands on d3
now this is an excellent square for the
knight however there is one downside to
it
uh the problem is uh you will have uh
issue
uh pushing uh c3 at any point if the c3
pawn is the only thing
guarding this knight here so rook f2b1
alireza adds
more uh firepower to the a and b line uh
and now
rook to a6 blocking the a pawn another
idea here
uh was e5 but uh it's just uh
it's just an idea that's constantly in
the position but you never know
when when to play it and i will show you
uh what i mean by this so first rook
after b1
and here fabi blocks it would work to a6
and then now rook to b5
all it is it just grabs more space
everything is just
nicely defended and you don't have a
light square bishop to attack this rook
you only have a dark square bishop and
the knight which
and it's very unlikely that you can ever
attack this rook and here is what i mean
by this here
e5 is an incredibly complicated move
because it
um it allows whites to go for this
beautiful sacrifice knight captures on
c4
captures on c4 and now queen captures on
c4
attacking the knight here e captures on
the e4 we have queen captures on d3
uh and now of course you cannot capture
because the bishop is hanging but you
can play
uh rook to d8 and then you allow e
captures on d4
and uh we would get this position where
uh everything is completely crazy
uh fabi would be up a bishop but alireza
would have three pass pawns uh
for that bishop and it's uh well it's
just
incredibly difficult to play for black
because uh i mean that queen and rook
can never move if those pawns start
uh marching out the board it's just game
over and it's very hard to say if black
would be able to withstand the pressure
here
so while e5 is a constant idea fobby
still
waits with it so here he first brings
the rook to c4
uh the c8 now adding additional
protection to that c
pawn and now you are also aligning
aligning it
with the queen so here uh rook 8 the b1
by ferruja
uh you could also instead of rocate the
b1 go e4 e4 is also a constant idea in
the position because
you just allow for example if d captures
an e4
knight captures on c4 and it's just a
beautiful position for white
it doesn't matter that you've allowed
this queen to now be fully aligned with
the rook for example if queen c6
attacking the knight
just b7 and i mean you you can see that
good things are happening
you if rook to b8 then you don't no
longer have to worry about the knight
just queen to b3
and you are making excellent progress
here so after this rook the c8 move we
have rook a to b1 by ferruja
and now comes h6 here both players just
uh waste a little bit of tempi
uh to make some breeding room for their
kings uh so g3
again uh waiting with the c4 idea g3 by
alireza
and now bishop back to e7
uh we have e4 finally by alireza
but now e5 finally fabi goes for it we
have bishop to c3
and now it's a question what do you play
here uh
even feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the absolute best move
for fabi while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding
such a move as it's not an easy move to
find
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's d4
it seems seems rather obvious to play it
but uh you know
it uh well it just brings a whole lot
because after bishop to a1 you have to
find
knight to b4 and here just uh everything
completely explodes uh you are now
ready to push push these past pawns you
are giving up uh
uh well you you can grab a knight and
bishop for a rook here
but it all works out very nicely for
example rook captures on b4 bishop
captures rook captures and you can now
eliminate the a5 pawn as well
which means you will eliminate the b6
pawn and then i mean this massive pawn
chain here against
one extra piece uh white white's going
to have a terrible time defending this
so
while you could play something like
bishop to b2 as your bishop was hanging
you would then allow c3 which is
completely winning for black
and if you decide to give back the piece
to win back some of the pawns for
example characters and
captures well obviously not with the
queen but for example knight captures on
c4
uh you can then play queen to a7 attack
the rook here and after you move the
rook for example rook to b1 you're gonna
go rook eight to c5 put pressure on the
on the knight here and it's just a very
uh very interesting position where where
black will always be better yes white
still has a pass pawn here but uh
black's pass pawn is stronger and you
you never have to worry about this rook
the b8 is coming
so it's just a really really crazy
position and
i think calculating all of this from
this position where alireza played
bishop to c3
uh would just require too much time and
this is not a classical game this is
norma getting game so of course uh
the the the pressure is unfobby to
decide what to do here so here fabi
plays bishop to c5 instead
uh he puts uh pressure on the f2 pawn
now wants to capture this but now he
gives alireza
uh the opportunity he needed and alireza
goes for it
rook captures on c5 so he gives up the
exchange
knight captures on d5 and only now e
captures on d5 so grabbing the d5 pawn
queen captures and now queen to f5 uh
alireza goes for that
rook on c8 we have rook to d8 and now
comes
rook to b5 pinning that knight so now
the knight cannot move
and you can't really break through the d
file as the bishop is
nicely defending the knight here you're
keeping an eye on the a5 pawn
so it's not that easy for black to to
decide what to do
here we have f6 as that e5 pawn is
uh looking pretty well maybe not weak as
the bishop is still uh
guarding that knight here but fabi wants
to uh just uh strengthen the position so
he pushes f6 and
now b7 by ferruja so now
b8 is coming you have to defend that we
have queen to d6 now both the queen
and the rook are guarding this but now
comes a beautiful move by alderesa
queen to c8 now just uh threatening to
i had to promote the pawn of course if
you capture the queen then you've just
given up a rook because white instantly
gets another queen into the game
and fabi is forced to go into a very
very unfavorable favorable end game for
him uh which starts with
knight characters on b7 so you have to
give up the knight here
and there was uh not nothing better to
uh to be done here so queen captures and
now
uh queen to c6 just uh immediately
offering a queen trade
uh and you will have to you will you
will have to try and hold on to this end
game so queen captures on c6 we have
rook captures
and rook to b6 now here alireza says
uh okay i have a bishop and knight for
your rook let's trade a pair of rooks
and i'm i'm down with playing this
uh fabi says okay we're gonna we're
gonna wait a bit we're not just gonna
trade everything just yet and alireza
continues pushing
a6 as this game is all about the pushing
you can see from the title from the
quote above the board
so we're just pushing this game a6 uh we
have rook to a8
fabio of course blocks the queening
square and puts pressure on the a6
pawn and now comes knight to e4 now the
knight is also coming
uh to help out we have rooked the c7 and
now of course
knight to c5 regarding that ace a6 pawn
and there isn't uh well there just isn't
much you can do here
uh if you allow something like rook to
b7 to be played
that's uh pretty much game so here rook
the c8
putting pressure on the knight here but
now rook to b5 just keeping the tension
defending the knight the knight
nicely defends the a6 pawn all is well
here
we have h5 by fabi and now h4
and king king to h7 uh we have king to
g2
and king to g6 both players improving
the position of their kings king f3 king
to f5 and king to e3 by alireza
uh we have rook to c6 fabby sees that uh
well there's
not much we can do here at some point we
will have to give up the rook for that
pawn
as there is nothing much to be done here
so here we have
bishop to b4 uh and now here
uh while you could try and prolong the
game with something like g5 you can just
play captures captures king of three so
not
not much for uh for black to do here so
fabi instead
goes for something uh well rather
extraordinary he plays
c3 he gives up uh the pawn here uh so he
can grab the
a6 pawn uh with with this idea so bishop
captures on c3
but now he doesn't go for it right away
for example if rookie captures siri
rook characters and you can capture the
bishop here uh he doesn't like playing
against the knight so he would much
rather play against the bishop so here
he just plays king to g6 and now
bishop back to b4 but now he goes for
rook captures on a6 and now he's going
to play against the bishop
rather than the knight so knight
captures and rook captures and here
fabi is up upon but alireza has a bishop
so
can you can you even play this let's see
how fabi does it we have rook to be
seven by elireza going for that bishop
the f8 move so you can capture on
uh on g7 which is the game then uh so
rook to a8 not allowing the bishop to
land on f8 we have king to e4
now of course if you push then king can
capture and now rook to d8 trying to cut
off the white king
but just bishop the c5 not allowing any
rook to d4 ideas we have rook back they
ate by fabi
and now king to d5 we have rook to a5
now uh pinning the bishop uh rook to a7
of course uh alireza wants that wants to
get rid of that rook so rook the b5 and
now
king the c c6 attacking the rook rook to
b2
it doesn't matter because this bishop is
regarding the df2 pawn so we don't have
to worry about anything here
king to d5 now again pinning the bishop
but now king to c4 we have rook to b8
and
now rook to c7 guarding the bishop from
this side and now
the king will finally be able to enter
the game with rook to a8
and the king to d5 now uh now there is
no
really no point in going rook to a5
because the regards the bishop
so here we have rook the a2 uh sorry
about that
they seem to be drilling something right
uh uh in front of my door sorry if you
can hear that
uh king the e6 and now rook to a6
with check we have king e7 and now
king f5 fabi starts bringing his king
deeper into the position and now king to
f7
going after this g7 pawn with g5 by fabi
and now bishop to e3 saying okay you're
welcome to capture that
i don't really mind uh we have g
captures on h4
g captures on h4 and now king to g4
fabio would be incredibly happy if he
could capture on
h4 here however rook to c for check by
alireza forcing the king to go back and
now just
king to g6 the h pawn will now be
eliminated and it's uh well it's just
going to be very hard for fabi to defend
this with
e4 by fabi and king captures on h5
we have f5 now hoping to get this uh
f4 move in but king to g5 now the f4
square is nicely guarded by the king and
by the bishop
we have rook to a5 now not allowing the
push as
it would be checked here uh and here you
don't really have much to do rook the c5
is one way to go about it as you pretty
much take care of everything
uh bishop to f4 the move alireza plays
is a different way to go about it
because you simply don't allow the f4
move
so uh here we have uh just king captures
on f2 grabbing that pawn
fabi now also has a pass pawn well two
of them
uh and rook to c to check we have king
to f3 and
now uh rook to c3 pushing the king
further back king e2 and now
h5 alareza starts pushing his pass pawn
we have rooked a1 uh and now
trying to get the get some checks in and
control the pass pawn from here
but just h6 we have rooked h1 and
now king captures on f5 so only one pass
pawn for
fabi left and the e3 square is guarded
so there's not much you can do here king
to f2 is played
but just king captures on e4 as there is
no way to protect it
haso king captures on e4 and it was in
this position that fabiano corwana
resigned the game and
a beautiful victory uh for alireza
ferruga in round three
uh not in classical but in armageddon
but still just
just a wonderful victory here you resign
because whatever you do
let's say you go rook to h4 you try
something just rook c to check and then
after the
king moves you can just play for example
rook to h2 and
that that's game you either trade rooks
and then the h pawn uh queens or you
well not
that but you can try and prolong with
rook to g4 but just h7 you guard the
g8 there there are no moves here for
black
so after this king captures an e4 idea
fabio resigned and a beautiful beautiful
victory for
young alireza here and we're going to
show the standings one more time i don't
know if
all of you have seen the standing so
these are the standings and it's pretty
incredible
magnus again yes he wins the event one
full uh
round before the tournament ended but
second place alireza firuja ahead of
some very very strong names like levan
aaron and fabiana karwana youngshish of
duda
and aryanthari and it's uh it's a very
interesting event
with a very interesting time format so
first you play a classical game
and then after the classical game you
immediately play the armageddon
so you we cannot have a tie like if we
draw
the classical game we immediately go
into armageddon and then someone
has to win and with this setup with this
sort of a
modern time uh time format uh young
alireza
was able to clinch second place ahead of
some
well some legendary names here so it's
going to be
it's going to be very interesting to see
how he will do in future classical
events because i don't think we have a
classical event
that immediately goes into armageddon
after after this i think they tried
something
at the gibraltar or they were planning
on doing something but
uh other than uh the ultibox norway
championship i don't think there's
such an event i could be wrong though i
could be talking nonsense
uh we're gonna blame blame it on the
anesthesia as usual but
uh you know i don't think there is one
so really really amazing stuff we'll see
what happens in the future alireza
really
uh you know if magnus was not here i
mean
we would have already in front of all of
these names so you know
the future of chess is is in good hands
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it like i said we
probably will cover some other games so
i'm gonna go through them
uh you know just to check if there are
some interesting ones and uh once
once we're done with that we're gonna
continue of course none other than the
paul morphy saga
uh so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it
i would like to thank andrea silvestri
jonathan mallett
v lawrence coker uh doro koticoglu and
malachi havahan
for your contribution to my channel uh
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing probably the this short
coverage of the altibook story
championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day